.
IF I CAN HAVE THE FIRST SL, WAHT
THY, AND THEMMUNITY OF THE AMERO
NG
THINGS FOR THE NEXT 30 D TO
FFERENCE.
I INT
OU THAT YOU C BEHIND
TO THANK THE FIVEIX
INTERNATIONAL FROM HARVARD, FRO
NORTHEASEMPIRICAL,
WHO HEL EMENDOUSLY, MODELS THA
BI
MITIGATIONS COULD HOWEEEP FROM
N U SUCCUMBING TO THIS VIRUS
OU MITI
YET THROUGHHE
STSHATISTANC
WOULD HAF PEOPLEHOMEATF
PEOPLE WERAR TO AND WORRY ABOUT
TONGCES, WHAT AN
EXTRAORDIN T C IFRY AMERICAN FOD
IT TAKES USO THAT STIPPLED
MOUNTAINT'H LOWER,
HILL, ACTUALLY,N TO100
20HI I
WAY TOO MUCH.
NEXT SLIDLE
SIMULTEO
MODELER OUTE UNI OF
WASHIN MODELLEM
UP UTILIZING T
ROUND THEBE
LY UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
INFORMATION THAT HAVEALY AND SP
AND CHINA RPGIVE INSIGHT INTO H
NEED NEEDS, THE
WHO POTENTIALLYDMB IT IS THIODT
INT US MOST OE
COURSE THAT IS POSSIBLE.
BUT THIS MODEL ASSUMESMITIGATIO.
IT'S INFORMEDVERY OR  BY THE REE
UNITED STIS MLE AND I
EVERY SO THAT IT IS
ADJU, UPY DAY.
THIS IS THF EDICTE FATALITIES A.
AS THE PRESIDENT VERMUCH FOCUSE.
NEXT SLIBUT TH I ADEES
US GREAT HOPE AND
ABOUT WHAT I POSS
AT THE BOTME
WHEREYSEE,
UE LINE AT THE VERY, THAT'S THES
IN CALIFORNIA, WHERE TREING STE
TH NEW
THE BLUEE IS NEW RK
THE YELLOW LINE
WE ALL REMEMBERNGTON
STATE.
IT WAS JUST ATHN
THEY STARTED TO HAVE THE ISSUES.
BUHEYROUGHT TOGETHERHEUNND THEIR
MITI ANDTEST
AND YOU C
IN WASHIIAOUT THE C FORTH NEX AD
CHANGE.
E YOU'RE INTERTED IN
SEEING ALL TSTATES. SLIDE IS AL
MAINTAINHILOSES.
HOPE WE DON'T HAVE
SIGNIFICANT S IN
STATES INTHERAS.HE COMESHER
TOOG THAT
EALTH CAREUN
THE GLOBE ANDRE O  MATBYS COMTY
UN ALL KNOWE ARE IN
STATES AND COMMUNITIES.Y ONAC I
DOING THAME THING.
LLTHELGUIDES TO A TEE
I T'S ASK BYOU HAVE DONE5 DHOW
PLEASE.
THIS I
TH CASEE THEEOHENEW CASES.THEY T
WEEK OF FULL
SHOWING WHAT WHEN WE
WOHESCOUNTR THE C S THISGRHI THS
POSSIBLE WITH CONTINUING FOR
ANOTHER 30 ALL OFHAOP
SAY THATNED TROIT AND CHICAGO, O
CHANGES IN MASSACHUSETTS.
AN A
PROBLEM OFOUGH TAR SHOWSEPTH O
TS EUR DOCTOR,RESPIRATORYERCIST
TOGETHER TO STEM THIS TIED OF
UNRELENTG TO DOORS.
NO O HASNEWANE THAT H
VENTILAT
VENTILN. YOU HOW SES ON THEM.
I KWS STRESSFW
THE GUES, B IT IS MORE
DIFFICULTOU DS.> ISLEPY.'S JUSTS
THAT TWO
FORCES OPPOSING EACH
OTHE MONEVERAL T IN
OUIE S,LEFT T I D WILL DAR DR.
THE OTH FORCE I
WE T DO ANDIL
MITIGATION.W ARE V REVEALING
BITS OF DAT Y
LY YOU
MAKE THE CVE.
THAT DOESN'TLL AONCE.
IT ISP WISE FASHION. E THEWIOU N
GO TNGE WHAT YOU HAVE IS REASEN
AT ATAIN RATE.
ENASE CASES
TO LEVELOFF, SECONDARY CTHOSPIT
DEATHS.
THE DEATHSHERE IN HOSPIZA
ALWAYS LAG BEHIND THAT EARLYCAT
LIKELY SEEING -- I DON'T WANT
JUMPHE GUN -- BUTAREEE NEW YORK
YOU SOUGHT AND NEW RSEY AHE CLER
PLACES THAT HAV GOTTEN TO
THAT OTTI15 DAYS
CLEARLY HAS HAD AN OU T T
SE O TWO FORCES. FTRONGLEC THEAE
NOW WHEN YOU ARE
N TAKE
THEOOT OFF T A
ON T  JT THE ACCELERATOR.
THAT'S WHATOPE ANDW
CAN DO OVEREXT 30 DAYS.
T DAY IN ONE
THE
WE ARE A VERY AND
IF YOU LK N THROU SOMEDES. TOUG
STS WILL BE TANSWER TO THE MS LD